[Music]
welcome
hey guys it's Justine and today I am so
excited because I have the new iPhone
14s right here and we're going to be
testing them out today we're testing out
the camera system it has a new 48
megapixel sensor we have the new action
mode and of course the new 4k cinematic
mode there's so many more things that
we're going to be testing but come on
let's not waste any time
we're starting this out with some
front-facing video they've updated the
front-facing camera now so everything
looks so much clearer and crisper look
at all my friends they have three
cameras I have one and the crazy part is
those are also all 4K like we're all
shooting four things
[Music]
the iPhone 14 pro Max does have an
upgraded camera system and there is a
noticeable size difference between the
12 13 and the new 14 camera bumps so the
14 is significantly larger than the 12.
slightly larger than the 13 but you can
definitely tell when you put them up
close to each other that is some
improved camera quality for us new
iPhones means we must protect them at
all costs now dbrand has been my number
one go-to screen protector over the past
couple of years ever since they started
doing these tempered glass screen
protectors I sent them a message and I
was like you better be making iPhone 14
protective screen displays because I
don't know how I'll live without it I
have tried so many other ones and I kid
you not it has been by far the best
thing ever so what's great is is when
you buy one of the screen protectors it
actually comes with two
squeegee going in
and there it is look at that it's so
clean that I think that maybe I might
need to do a little
damage a little damage if you will
[Music]
I'm trying to stab it and nothing is
happening
Link in the description
I'm out
[Music]
the main camera is 48 megapixels with a
quad pixel sensor and the second gen
sensor shift Optical image stabilization
now this is where the lens will actually
shift to give you a much more stable
image it has two times better low light
photos and a new 20 millimeter focal
length the ultra wide lens is an F 2.2
with three times more improved low light
and a sharper lens that will improve the
overall quality of macro shots macro was
first introduced in the iPhone 13 so I'm
so glad to see them improving it in the
14. the telephoto is an F 1.78 that
allows for a new 2x mode in addition to
the 3x the front-facing and the rear
cameras will all shoot 4K video you can
shoot in 24 30 and 60 frames a second if
you want to do slo-mo that's using 1080p
120 and 240 frames a second another fun
thing is you can also record prores
video that will also work on the
front-facing camera which is pretty fun
I don't normally shoot a lot of prores
on my phone but the fact that you can do
this is pretty incredible now prores is
a much larger video file size so if you
are planning to shoot prores make sure
you do have one of the larger bones
because you're definitely going to be
eating up storage very very quickly
something that I learned recently from
the younger generation I am
unfortunately I don't think I can
consider myself the younger generation
anymore that you guys call it 0.5 like
we always call it the wide angle camera
but you guys call it 0.5 deliberately
you're like hey can you point five me
didn't even know it was a thing I
freaking love it okay so we're in point
five right now let's go to one and this
is kind of what it would look like if
you were vlogging holding the phone out
let's go to two now two is the new focal
length that they have which is kind of
cool to have that kind of in between and
now we're gonna go to full telephoto
three that's probably so close to my
face isn't it
yeah
geez
oh yeah there we go basically don't ever
Vlog in in three you don't want to do
that so I want to test out what it looks
like when you're shooting in prores or
not now I like prores when there's a lot
of colors and when I know that I'm going
to have time to go in and actually edit
it because with prores you'll have so
much more data that you'll actually be
able to pull out colors and make it look
just how you like it so these are both
the iPhone 14 pro Maxes this is just the
smaller version and the iPhone 14 pro
Max and purple is shooting in prores and
the iPhone 14 in space black is shooting
not in prores camera systems are
identical so these should look exactly
the same except one is prores
and one is not get some Sky some
Greenery look at that look at those
shrubs get a little blue I hate not
having cases on these but I didn't want
to have cases so you guys can actually
see the beautiful colors but normally in
my everyday life I'm a case person 100
percent
[Music]
foreign
is definitely way more crisp now I am
taking some photos and video here and
it's crazy because as soon as I took my
ice cream outside like I can actually
see the sprinkles they started to sweat
like there's beads of sweat on the
sprinkles because it's so hot out here I
cannot see that with my normal everyday
basic eye when we go in there with this
macro you can see the beads of water
on these sprinkles this is fantastic
like I can get so close it gets crazy
how close I can get like I'm actually
able to see the beads of sweat on these
sprinkles like I'm so close to the
sprinkles like I feel like I am
Oh no I got ice cream on my phone I'll
try like my phone
zero judgment maybe a little bit I
deserve it but it's ice cream is so good
I'm gonna go get a napkin that's
disgusting I'm disgusting the covert
times so now on the iPhone 14 pro Max
you have a 2X telephoto option which
will bring you to a 0.512 and three now
on the iPhone 14 just regular no Pro you
have the 0.5 and the 1X so that is kind
of the trade-off if you are getting the
14 you're not going to be getting that
telephoto zoom and I'll tell you what I
love being able to have that telephoto
option because it gives you a lot more
flexibility in your photos and your
video
[Music]
now to demonstrate action mode I'm going
to reenact what just happened we saw
this little dog running around the
street didn't have a collar and I
freaked out I was like Jake get out of
the car go chase him I ditched my car
got out and we started chasing this dog
all around the town and then I tried to
grab him he bit my hand thankfully he
didn't break the skin or anything and so
we went in this back alley we saw some
crates so we both grabbed crates and
we're now running around trying to catch
this dog and this thing is so fast one
of his eyes was like so gray and I don't
think that he could even see and I'm
still so heartbroken about it so for the
rest of this video we're going to be
trying to hunt Louie I called him Louie
because we kept saying okay we're just
gonna do one more Loop one more Loop for
Louie so I'm hoping that we see him it's
like my heart is hurting so bad like
he's out there somewhere
anyway here's action mode get out go get
go get it go again go get it
[Music]
I think he's over here
I think he turned over here
[Music]
ready yep
let's go ready yep okay all right oh
geez you're already going
now we're gonna be testing out some of
the portrait mode photos on the 12 13
and 14 to see if there's any difference
at all
[Music]
so now we're going to take Raw photos on
all through the phones and see if we can
see the difference because the new 14 is
a new 48 megapixel raw photo so it's
definitely going to be way crisper
foreign
looking these photos back I gotta go
change my shirt because
I'm so sweaty
now cinematic mode was one of the big
new features last year so now I'm going
to test it out because it is 4K on the
new iPhone 14 and previously it was only
1080 and you could only record in 30
frames a second but now you can record
in 24 and in 4k so let's see what the
difference is all right so here it is
Cinematic mode so right now I'm in Focus
we're filming on both of the phones and
now we're gonna pop in and get that stop
sign in Focus so hello hi goodbye
come on
[Music]
there he is do we have a crate oh my God
I can't believe it
there he is
have you seen this dog around
[Music]
flowy
can you please don't bite me wait oh
gosh please don't go into traffic
back from Louis Expedition again we
still cannot find this dog it's breaking
my heart if anybody lives in Pomona and
you've seen this dog please keep a
lookout for him I'm so personally
invested now
I tried my best we all did it's night
time we're out here we are the night it
is time to take some photos now I've got
three phones here I've got the 12 the 13
and the new 14 pro Max now these are all
the Pro Models now in comparison to the
iPhone 13 the iPhone 14 Ultra wide is
three times brighter and the main camera
is two times brighter there's also some
improvements in the telephoto as well so
now it is time to test them out here we
go
[Music]
thank you
the iPhone 14 has a new 9 LED flash now
this is going to allow you to get a much
Brighter Image almost up to two times
brighter depending upon the lighting
conditions and it's called the Adaptive
true tone flash because it'll actually
adapt depending upon the conditions
surrounding your subject but also
depending upon the focal length that
you're shooting the photo hope to go
test them out and take some flash photos
that's a big freaking Roach
I'm gonna get him
oh I'm gonna puke
the thing that I definitely noticed in
looking at these photos is the skin tone
like they were not joking
like it's definitely a warmer tone and
then when you actually zoom in there is
definitely a noticeable difference
especially with the Flash
[Music]
so I'm going to take a photo of just of
the ground with a different focal
lengths just to see if we can see a
difference in the flash brightness
here's 0.5
[Music]
here's two
and here's three
[Music]
so to do a lot of this low light image
processing apple has a smooth thing
called the photonic engine now this is
using computational photography machine
learning hardware and software it's all
working together to get you a much
better low light image
[Music]
thanks
and that's a wrap on our iPhone 14
camera test video of course I'll be
posting a ton more on my tick tock on
Twitter on Instagram I even freaking use
Snapchat now I know I know I have a
bunch more iPhone and Apple videos that
I've made over the past couple of weeks
so make sure you guys check those out
here I will put them on the end screen
and if you haven't already please
subscribe and also hit the Bell so
you'll be notified when I post new
videos and I would love to hear from you
guys in the comments which photos look
the best to you is there anything that
we should have tested out that we didn't
let me know and you may see your
comments or your suggestions in a future
video I'm gonna go to bed now because I
am physically exhausted it's Apple
iPhone season and I'm sleepy
I'm out
[Music]